a magical moment to savour but also to
capitalize on if football is truly to be
a sport of equal opportunities
i can do a skill maybe a step over take
it the other way and then shoot all
right
this club for girls and young women
attracts players from across south
london the women's game has soared in
popularity and participation in recent
years we're really seeing the growth of
the game
to an exponential extent now
you know i think since the 2015 world
cup there was like something that wanted
to bubble
but some of the girls come here to play
football because they can't play it at
school it's the provision for girls to
play the game that's still lacking i've
seen that a lot of boys have a bit more
facilities than ours my brother he's
he does more tournaments
and
like more stuff
to be he's got more training sessions
currently more than a third of all
schools in england don't offer equal
access to girls football in pe lessons
the government says it's investing 230
million pounds to build or improve 8 000
grassroots football and multi-sport
facilities by 2025 and they must provide
access for women's and girls football
the fa says it will train over a
thousand more female coaches and
referees by 2024
it's hoped 120 000 more girls will play
football on the back of the tournament
but history shows just holding a
successful sporting event isn't enough
to create a legacy the interest has been
incredible hasn't it's a record ticket
sale to over half a million and i think
what's important to me is more than half
the ticket sales have gone to men and
boys so this is across the spectrum that
this is really popular and in this case
it can be a legacy as long as we can
invest in grassroots in opportunities in
changing the way we do things in march
the momentum in the female games saw 90
000 girls take part in the biggest ever
football session for girls in schools
abby sims was an ambassador for the
event
i think with the this euros especially
it just shows that it is an equal sport
and it does like women do deserve this
chance and they have taken it but the
big money remains in the men's game and
a visit to the luton birmingham match
showed not all football fans are
convinced equality is within reach
do you think there are some men who
still think that women should not be
playing football 100
i don't agree with them no
do you think the women's game will ever
enjoy the same level of support as men
no
i don't think that's ever going to be
the money in the women's game that there
is in the men's
but after the women's euros success
there's never been a better moment to
prove the doubt is wrong lisa holland
sky news